THE SENATE NATURAL RESOURCE IN
WATER COMMITTEE WELCOME BACK
THANK YOU TO. STAFF FOR KEEPING
A STEADY OVER THE BREAK- IT'LL
BE A BUSY YEAR BUT TODAY'S A
SHORT HEARING JUST ONE BILL IS
UP AND I THINK WE HAVE A QUORUM
PRESENT. SO AT YES DISTRICT
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS. OKAY
SO SERVICE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS- WE WANT TO
INTRODUCE OUR FELLOW FOR THE
YEAR- ANDHIS NAME IS GRAYSON
TO SET. HE IS A DOCTOR AS THEY
ALL ARE SO TO BE INTIMIDATED.
AND HE HAS A PHD IN MATERIALS
SCIENCE FROM PENN STATE
UNIVERSITY- WHERE YOU ACTUALLY
FOCUSED. ON SOLAR CELL
TECHNOLOGY IN A NUMBER OF OTHER
CHEMICAL ENGINEERING PUZZLES
THAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND- BUT-
THANKFULLY YOU'LL BE ASSISTING
THE COMMITTEE THIS YEAR SO WE
WELCOME YOU GRAYSON AND THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US- WITH THAT.
SECRETARY WOULD YOU MIND
CALLING THE ROLE HERE SURE
SENATOR STERN HERE'S STERN HERE
JONES JONES HERE ALLEN. THIS
ORDER IS HERE CAPPIELLO CAREER
HERE HER. JACKSON MONNING HERE
MONNING HERE. AND SO THANK YOU
FOR THE INDULGENCE I WILL HAND
THE GAVEL NOW TO VICE CHAIR-
THING IS I AM UP WITH THE LOAN
BILL TODAY. RIGHT. THANK YOU
CENTER STERN WILL BE ARE
PRESENTING SENATE BILL SEVEN
THIRTY NINE. AND I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT AN IS A MOTION TO
ADJOURN IF ANYBODY WOULD LIKE
TO. MR ON THE FLOOR IS YOURS
AND WE'RE ANXIOUSLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO YOUR PRESENTATION
THEY CAN SHARE. MEMBERS WE'VE
BEEN. THROUGH PROBABLY EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF US ON THIS
COMMITTEE IN ONE WAY SHAPE OR
FORM- HIT BY THE WILDFIRE
DISASTERS- AND SURPRISE THE
WORK IS NOT DONE EVEN THOUGH WE
WRAPPED UP LAST SESSION AFTER A
FEW FLURRY OF WORK. WHEN IT
COMES TO ISSUES A DEFENSIBLE
SPACE RIGHT AROUND THE HOME%
ZERO TO FIVE FEET THAT SEEM
LIKE NOT THAT BIG OF A DEAL
COMPARED TO THE MAGNITUDE OF.
FORCE THAT NEED TO BE- A WILD
LANDS ARE SORT OF INTIMIDATING
LEE LARGE LANDSCAPES WHEN YOU
GO DOWN TO THE SMALL WHICH IS
JUST. RIGHT OUTSIDE YOUR DOOR
ALL ALONG YOUR HOUSE. BOB YOUR
GARAGE ON THE VENTS OF YOUR
WINDOWS. THOSE ARE THE LIFE AND
DEATH MAKE OR BREAK PLACES
THAT. TRULY FROM A FIRE SIZE
PERSPECTIVE. WILL MAKE US
RESILIENT- IN ADDITION TO ALL
THE NATURAL AND MANAGEMENT WE
NEED TO DO IS A THIS BILL. IS
TRYING TO. PULL OUT A PIECE OF
A OF LEGISLATION THAT IT WORKED
ON LAST YEAR DILIGENTLY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AS PART
OF A BIGGER PACKAGE THAT WAS
VETOED- YOU FEEL THOUGH THAT.
THE MINIMUM. THE COMPONENT
SEVEN THIRTY NINE ARE SORT OF
NO BRAINER AS WE GET THAT MAY
THERE MAY BE SOME CONTROVERSY
ALTHOUGH I STILL THINK. THAT
WAS A VERY SOLID WELL THOUGHT
THROUGH MEASURE BUT- THERE'S
SOME SENSITIVITIES AROUND.
ENFORCEMENT OF DEFENSIBLE
SPACE- AND EXACTLY HOW YOU
FINANCE SOME OF THIS IN THE
IMPACT AS AN INSURANCE MARKETS
SO WHAT WE KNEW WHAT WE DO TO.
PEOPLE THIS IS A MAJOR OWN CAN
DO AND IT ISN'T SOMETHING THAT
THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY HAS THE
RIGHT DATE ON IT ISN'T
SOMETHING THAT FRANKLY ARE
COUNTIES ARE FIRST RESPONDERS
HAVE THE RIGHT DATA ON. IT
TAKES EYES AND EARS FIGURE OUT-
PEOPLE GASKET THEIR FENCE OR
THEIR GARAGE OR DONE SWEPT UP
THE LEAVES UNDER THE EAVES
EASIER. MAYBE WE GET TO AN AERO.
SOMEHOW ALL BE EXACTLY OR-
ECOLOGICALLY SOMEHOW SENSED BUT
RIGHT NOW IS GONNA BE A PEOPLE
PEOPLE POWER ISSUE AND SO THIS
BILL IS RELEASE. WAS TO GIVE A
CONDUIT TO WAKE UP COMMUNITIES
TO DEFEND THEMSELVES. AND THIS
IS IN- I DON'T I DON'T THINK
THIS IS POLITICAL OR EVEN IF
YOU'RE PASSED ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT OR IF YOU IF YOU
THAT DOESN'T REALLY WAKE YOU UP
IN THE MORNING- IF YOU'RE MORE
INTERESTED IN THE PUBLIC SAFETY
OF YOUR COMMUNITY I THINK I
TOOK ME LIKE. CHATSWORTH IN YOU
KNOW THE- THE VETERANS THE
SENIORS ARE OUT THERE DOING
NEIGHBORHOOD WATCH. RIGHT THERE
MAKING SURE THERE'S I'M ON THE
STREETS AND THAT'S WITH FOCUS
ON THEY'LL THINK M. AS AN OPERA
ABOUT. CHANGE BUT THEY ARE
WORRIED. THEIR NEIGHBORS HOUSES
IN DOWN JUST A RICH FIRE. WE
CAN ONLY DO SO ENGAGEMENT
THROUGH THE KIND OF TRAINING IS
CONSERVE THIS BILL MAY WE CAN
ACTUALLY START TO- GET
COMMUNITIES DOING THE HARD WORK
ON THE GROUND OF WORKING WITH
THEIR NEIGHBORS TO MAKE SURE
THEIR HOUSES ARE SAFE AND THEIR
NEIGHBORS NEIGHBORS HOUSE ARE
SAFE BECAUSE WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
IS BROUGHT TOGETHER IT DOESN'T
MATTER IF YOU JUST. FOR YOUR
HOME NOT ENOUGH YOUR NEW HOME
AS WE ARE IN TWO AND YOUR- THAT
IS YOUR ALL IN IT TOGETHER SO I
DON'T WANT TO OVER HYPE THE
BILL AND SAY THIS IS A SOME
SORT OF FIX TO CIVIC LETHARGY
THAT WE ARE. OUR SYSTEM BUT I
DO THINK. SOME SO I'M HAPPY
AGAIN TECH DETAILS BUT THAT'S
THE BILL AND I'VE MUCH SMARTER-
TECHNICALLY TRAINED FOLKS AND I
ARE HERE TO SUPPORT US WE WIDE
WIDE RANGE OF STAKEHOLDERS PORT
BUT THE RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICTS HERE AND THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY AS WELL- TO GIVE A
SORT OF SNAPSHOT OF. A WHY THIS
BILL SO THANK YOU AND ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT PLEASE. THANK YOU. AT
MY NAME IS KAREN BERGER I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICTS. AND WE'RE HERE A
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT SB SEVEN
THREE NINE WE FEEL LIKE IT WILL
HELP CALIFORNIA IN OR IN THE
IMPORTANT WORK THAT THEY
ALREADY DO A TO HELP
COMMUNITIES AND LANDOWNERS. BE
FIRE SAFE IN BOTH HAVING THE
TOOLS AND INFORMATION THEY
NEED- THE NINETY FIVE ARE
CITIES IN THE STATE- HAVE BEEN
PARTNERING WITH CAL FIRE FOR
DECADES TO DO THIS TYPE OF
WORK. AND AS THE FOLKS THAT
SAID AT THE INTERSECTION
AGRICULTURE CONST AND OUR
COMMUNITIES. EVERY DAY WE'RE
HEARING FROM LANDOWNERS THAT
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH
THAT THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT THE
SAFETY OF THEIR FAMILIES AND
THIS IS A REALLY PRESSING ISSUE
FOR THEM. THAT'S WHY WE THINK
THIS IS SO IMPORTANT AND THAT'S
WHY THE OUR CITIES HAVE TAKEN
ON THIS WORK FOR THE- LAST ADD.
YOU KNOW. DECADES ONE REALLY
GOOD EXAMPLE OF WHERE THIS IS
HAPPENING IS IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY- WHERE THE OUR CITY IS
WORKING HAND IN HAND WITH A
FIRE SAFE OR THE FIRE LOCAL
FIRE AGENCY IS THAT WHEN THEY
DO GO OUT AND DO INSPECTIONS-
THEY HAND OVER THE INFORMATION
FOR IT OUR CD AND OUR CD THEN
GOES OUT AND WORKS THAT
LANDOWNER TO FIND GRANTS TO
SECURE RESOURCES AND TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO THOSE
LANDOWNERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
NOT ONLY ARE THEY ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT BUT THEY'RE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT A CORRECT WAY. IT'S
IMPORTANT PARTNER. WE BUT A-
STATEWIDE EFFORT TO STANDARDIZE
THIS HOME HARDENING
INDEFENSIBLE SPACE. WILL REALLY
HELP US IN BEING ABLE TO WORK
WITH OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
LANDOWNERS. AND WILL ALSO BE
ABLE TO HELP CAL FIRE IN
ADVANCING THE GOALS THAT
THEY'VE ALREADY BEEN WORKING SO
HARD ON. SO WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND WE URGE YOU TO
VOTE YES ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU ON BOB RAN CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION I
IN A BEEN WORKING WITH BUILDING
CODES FOR CLOSE TO FOUR DECADES
NOW. NORMALLY TAKES A COUPLE OF
DECADES TO ACQUIRE PHIL DATA
SHOW THAT A CERTAIN SET OF
BUILDING STANDARDS REACHING THE
GOALS THAT- BUT WE'RE DESIRED
WHEN THEY WERE FIRST DVELOPED
AND ADOPTED THAT'S NOT THE CASE
WITH THE WILDLAND URBAN FIRE
SAFETY RAKES WITHIN JUST A
COUPLE YEARS. OF THEIR
MPLEMENTATION BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT- WE HAD GOOD
SHOWING THAT A WORDS ARE MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE COMBINATION OF
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE
BUILDING STANDARDS EIGHT OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION SENSIBLE SPACE
IS BASIC. BOX ALL WAITED TO
FIGHT THIS AND WE NEED BOOTS ON
THE GROUND. AND THIS BILL GETS
UP MOVING FORWARD A KEY PART
HERE IS A EELOPING
TRAINING WE NEED THAT FROM SAN
DIEGO TO YUBA CITY TO EUREKA-
AND THAT'S HOW WE HANDLE
BUILDING CODES AND SO INDUSTRY
IS READY TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THIS. AND ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE THANK YOU. THE
WITNESSES. IF YOU CAN STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION PLEASE.
DANIEL BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. IN MANY NIKOLINA NONE
IS A SAN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC
IN SUPPORT. ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. ANYONE IS IN
OPPOSITION. COMMENTS FROM THE
DIET SENATOR BOARD JUST. AJ
WANTED THANK A CENTER STERN ON
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. I THINK A- WE HAVE ALL
COMPOSITE OF DIFFERENT BILLS
THAT ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS ON
PUBLIC SAFETY AND FIRE
PREPAREDNESS STUFF LIKE THAT. I
HAPPEN TO REPRESENT A FORMER
LIFE THE AREA THAT ABUTTED THE
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER A LOT OF
HOMES AROUND THERE AND I
CREATED SOME DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
PROTOCOLS ARE NOT ONLY FOR THE
PRIVATE- HOMEOWNER BUT ALSO
GUIDANCE ON PUBLIC LANDS. AND
I'M WONDERING DO YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS ON TO DO. TO PRIVATE
LAND. GIVE A THOUGHT ON THE
GLANDS THAT ABOUT THIS AREA IN
MAYBE DO NOT ALLOW FOR THAT
FULL I GUESS HUNDRED FEET.
DEFENSIBLE SPACE. WITH
SOMETHING LIKE THIS BE
APPLICABLE TO PUBLICLY. I THINK
THROUGH THE INSPECTION PROCESS
YOU PROBABLY START TO GET TO
THE TENSION POINTS IN A
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY SO YEAH
THE PRIVATE LANDOWNER GOES DOWN
THE HILLSIDE CUTS OFTEN THAT IT
FILTERS INTO PARKER BLM OR
CONSERVANCY RIGHT. IN THEORY I
THINK YOU'D YOU'D SIR X. ALL
THOSE ARE ATTENTION POINTS.
THIS BILL ISN'T ABOUT THE MONEY
PART OF IT- BUT THE FACT IS
THAT WHAT WOULD. HE INJURED
ABILITY TO REALLY GO AFTER THE
PUBLIC LAND SIDE AS THE IN M.
BUDGET. FOR A PARKS CONSERVANCY
I THINK WE CAN GET THROUGH THE
RIGHT WHATEVER REGULATORY
ANXIETY THERE MIGHT BE SAY LIKE
ME WHEN WE WERE IN MALIBU YOU
HAVE SOME ENVIRONMENTALLY
SENSITIVE HABITAT THAT WERE IN
THE MIDDLE OF TRYING TO PREVENT
A MUD SLIDE AND YOU NEED TO PUT
QUE RAILS AND- DEPARTMENT. IF
YOU IF YOU'RE TALKING LIKE LIFE
AND DEATH. FOR THAT KIND OF
DEFENSIBLE SPACE A MAINTENANCE
BUT- WE'VE GOT TO SOLVE THE
RESOURCE QUESTION I THINK AT
THE SAME TIME THAT WE GO FIND
IT SO I GUESS THIS IS THE GO
FIND IT PART. I'M NOT PROMISING
THAT. CHALLENGE BUT I DO THINK
WE'LL FOR WILL FIND THOSE SPOTS
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA JUST HAFTA
WERE THROWN SO I APPRECIATE
BRING THAT UP AND NEVER
APPROPRIATE AND I'D CERTAINLY
MAKE A MOTION TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD- IF THERE IS AN-
FEDERATION WHERE THAT'S CALLED.
A CONTEMPLATED. I THINK THERE
NEED BE SOME CAN. OF THE
CROSSOVER TERRITORY- BUT AS A
FIRST STEP FANTASTIC THANK YOU
CENTER WHICH WAS ON THIS POINT
I'VE GOT TWO OTHER SPEAKERS AT
WHAT ON THAT QUESTION I JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY REGARDING THE
ANSWER THE BILL SAYS THE. THE
TRAINING PROGRAM WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO PREPARE INDIVIDUALS
TO CONDUCT DEFENSIBLE STATE
ASSESSMENTS IN STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA. SO IT'S
NOT JUST ON PRIVATE PROPERTY IS
THAT CORRECT. CORRECT OKAY JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT
INTERJECTION. I THINK OBVIOUSLY
TO EMPOWER PEOPLE IS VERY
IMPORTANT DURING THESE
FEEL HELPLESS WHEN A FIRE COMES
OR WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO
ANTICIPATE FIRE SEASON SO I DO
APPRECIATE THE CONCEPT OF THE
BILL. I ALSO JUST WANTED TO.
REITERATE THE OBSERVATION BY
THE ANALYSES THAT. IT'S I THINK
THE KEY TO THIS IS MAKING SURE
THAT THE FRAMEWORK THAT IS
ULTIMATELY DEVELOPED IS ONE
THAT DOESN'T GIVE PEOPLE SOME
FALSE SENSE OF SECURITY. AND
GIVE THEM FALSE BUT THEY
EVERYTHING ABOUT EVERYTHING.
AND TO IN THIS THOSE VIEWS ON
WHAT. IS AND WHAT HAVE YOU BUT
SHOWS GIVES PEOPLE ARE THE
INFORMATION IN THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HELPFUL AND SO I THINK
THERE'S OF THERE'S A FINE LINE
TO THAT- BUT I DO THINK IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE
KNOW. WHAT STEPS ARE AVAILABLE
I KNOW HAVING GONE THROUGH THE
FIRES IN MY DISTRICT AND I KNOW
YOU'VE HAD A NUMBER IN YOURS
WE'VE ALL I THINK PROBABLY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE EXPERIENCE
THESE- THAT THE- HAVING
INFORMATION AND BEING EMPOWERED
TO ACT. IS VERY VERY CRITICAL
TO GET THROUGH THESE. DISASTERS
AND ALSO BE ABLE TO PROTECT OUR
HOMES AND OUR FAMILIES WHICH IS
REALLY. THE ALMOST EXCLUSIVE
CONSIDERATION WHEN SOMETHING
LIKE THIS HAPPENS SO I WOULD
CHOOSE- LIKE TO REITERATE. THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ADDITIONAL
KILEY GUIDANCE AND TIMELINESS
FOR THE SAD PARTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE CLEAR METRICS AND
WHAT IT IS YOU WANT TO EDUCATE
PEOPLE TO KNOW AND TO. AND TO
BE ABLE TO DO- AND TO BE ABLE
TO BRING THAT BACK SO WE FIND
OUT WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
ACTUALLY WORKING. THAT I WOULD
HAVE MOVED BILL IF IT. AND EVER
REALLY MOTIONS HEY. THESE TAKE
NOTE WE'VE MOVED A BILL TO GET.
IT IS A KNOWS THEIR FIRST AND
IS A NOTE- YEAH YEAH I GUESS I
HAVE A TWO PARTS TO IT AND- AND
I'M I'M REALLY FOLLOWS UPON
SOMETHING THAT SENATOR
JACKSON'S TALKING ABOUT- AND
THERE'S IT'S A SERIES OF
QUESTIONS I THINK THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO PUT SME RESOURCES TO.
HELPING PEOPLE FIGURE OUT HOW
TO HARDEN. AROUND THEIR HOMES
BUT. BUT IN DOING THAT THE
QUESTION BECOMES. WHAT HAPPENS
ONCE. THE INFORMATION IS
COLLECTED BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING
AROUND IN YOUR TALKING TO
PEOPLE I AM ASSUMING THAT
THEY'RE COLLECTING INFORMATION
ON HERE'SWHAT YOU NEED TO DO
IN ORDER TO HARDEN YOUR HOME
WHO GETS THAT INFORMATION IS AT
THE LOCAL COUNTY THAT GETS IT
IS IT A STATE. AGENCY THEY GET
THAT. ARE WE GONNA AT AND THIS
MAY BE THE SUBJECT OF ANOTHER
BAYLOR GONNA HAVE- GRANTS FOR
HOMEOWNERS. SO THAT THEY CAN
COME IN AND SOME OF IT IS
VEGETATION BUT SOME OF IT IS
THE- IS ARE THE VENTS AND THE
THINGS THAT WILL COST
HOMEOWNERS MONEY. YEAH AND- AND
THEN ARE THERE COMPLIANCE
REQUIREMENTS IN OTHER WORDS YOU
BETTER DO IT OR ELSE AND WHO
WILL WHO IS WHO'S DOING THE ARE
OR ELSE. AND ARE THEY GET IN A
PERIOD OF TIME IN ORDER TO MAKE
IT HAPPEN. AND THEN PART OF
THAT I THINK I WOULD THINK.
PART OF THE ANALYSIS HAS TO BE.
LOOKING FOR AND ENFORCEMENT AND
I'M LOOKING FOR. WE JUST ALL IT
CLICK ABOUT WHAT WE'RE SITTING
UP AT. YOU KNOW UPON YOUR ON
THE- GO OUT. I LEARNED NOT. TO
ME. BETTER SOMETHING UP AND TO
WHO IS LOOKING AT LANDSCAPING
BECAUSE I WAS. WE HAVE. THIS
INTERFACE IN MANY COMMUNITIES
WHERE WE HAVE. AB. FOLIAGE THAT
IS NOT NATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
THAT WE'VE PLANTED THAT. THAT
IT CAN BE- IS VERY FIRE PRONE I
WAS SHOCKED TO SEE THAT- PALM
TREES LIKE UP LIKE ROMAN
CANDLES WHO KNEW RIGHT BUT IT'S
LIKE HELLO IT'S FULL OF OIL AND
SO. AND EUCALYPTUS IS BUT WE
THEM LINING MANY STREETS AT
PARTICULARLY AS YOU COME DOWN
OUT OF THE FOOT HILLS AND SO-
IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT WE
OUGHT TO BE SMARTER ABOUT HOW
WE'RE DOING THINGS BECAUSE IT
REALLY IS A NEW NORMAL AND
WITHOUT AT. IT WE ALSO OUGHT TO
HAVE LANDSCAPING AND ADVICE IN
TERMS OF THESE KINDS OF THINGS
ARE DANGEROUS TO HAVE CLOSE TO
YOUR HOME AND I A- I AM A VIDEO.
AIR IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
HAPPEN TO BE CLOSE TO WHERE MY
FOLKS WHERE AND I WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT IT AND- THE CAMERA WAS
JUST LOOKING UP THE HILLS AND A
ROMAN CANDLE IN THE PICTURE LET
UP THERE WAS NOTHING CLOSE TO
IT IT JUST LET AT. AND THAT'S
BECAUSE IT BIRDS ARE FLYING.
AND IT WAS A SHOCK TO ME
BECAUSE LINE OF MY FOR MY
PARENTS HOUSE SO I MEAN WE'RE
GONNA SING WAS HE WAS YOU TAKE
AN AMBER JUMPING THE ONE O. ONE
FREE WAY. IT THAT'S A YOU KNOW
I DON'T KNOW TAKING A FIVE
HUNDRED FOOT JUMP BINGO HALF
MILE JONES RIGHT I MEAN SO IT'S
NOT LIKE A THE FIRE ITSELF IS
BURNING PERHAPS. IS THAT WHAT
IT SLIPS THROUGH HITS THAT ONE
IGNITION POINT. I KNOW ARAMBULA
.COM AT THE START IN IN IN
DIRECT RESPONSE TO THAT AND
BOTH THE STAFF ANALYSIS IN THE
OPENING COMES TO SENATOR MADE.
UP AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN INDEED
GOT GOT VETOED- IT WAS
PROPOSING TO DO- FOUR FIVE VERY
IMPORTANT THINGS ALL OF WHICH
WE SUPPORTED- BUT THIS BILL.
THAT IS SORT OF TAKING ONE OF
THOSE COMPONENTS ARE IS LOOKING
AT THE- MOMENT OF THE
EDUCATIONAL AND CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM CERTAIN ONLY. I WAS
VERY IMPORTANT AND GUARDS TO
WEAR THIS GETS APPLIED YES IT'S
TAILORED FOR SRBS- BUT IN THE
BUILDING CODE WORLD ONE SH.
THAT DONE THE WORK'S DONE AND
WE CAN EXPAND TO JUST ANYTHING.
AND SO. THE POINT IS A GETS
THAT FRAMEWORK IN RIGHT. THAT
WE GET IN A PIGGY BACK ON TOP
FROM ELSEWHERE AND THAT'S THE
KEY POINT ONCE YOU GET THE- AND
TO TACK ON A THAT GOES TO IF
THERE IF YOU'RE NOT COMPLIANCE.
YOUR FIRE DEPARTMENT SO AND
JUST A MACINNES INS FOR FIRE
DEPARTMENT WITH- COMPETING
LEVELS I WOULD SAY OF
COMPLIANCE ONCE THEY COME IN
TACK THAT THAT NOTICE TO YOUR
DOOR OR TO YOUR GATE I WOULD
SAY IN VENTURA COUNTY WHEN THE
FIRE DEPARTMENT JUST. A HOP TO.
HE WON COUNTY OVER YOU KNOW IT
GETS MORE COMPLICATED BUT I. AT
LEAST THAT DATA WILL GO BACK TO
THE FIRE DEPARTMENTS AND SAVE
THEM SOME TIME AND MONEY SO
THEY GO. TO PINPOINT THOSE
HOUSES. ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
THE DíAS. CENTER STERN
REJECTED WE HAVE A MOTION AND
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE RESERVE
ENGAGEMENT I WOULD JUST I WOULD
WELCOME THERE IS MONEY IN THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ON THIS RIGHT I WOULD
JUST WELCOME ENGAGEMENT THIS
VEHICLE TO REALLY HELP YOUR
CONSTITUENCIES OWN WHATEVER THE
OUTCOME IS HERE AND MAKE THIS.
GIVEN ORGANIZING EXERCISE THAT
WE COULD BE IS IT FOR- BOUGHT
AND CENTER FOR THEIR FIRE SAFE
COUNCIL THEY WANTED WILL SPACE
WERE AND THE BUZZ IS OUT THERE
THE STATE MONEY COMES. TO
COMMUNITY IS. GREAT STATE
GOVERNMENT IS HERE TO HELP.
WE'VE GOT TO FIND SOME WAY TO
UNLOCK POTENTIAL IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS TO DO THAT SORT
OF THAT CIVIC WORK AND IT'S
SITTING HERE SO- I'D REALLY
WELCOME A PARTNERS ON ALL THIS
AND RESPECT. THANK YOU MA'AM
SECTORS KALRA. PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR STERN
AYE STERN AYE JONES JONES I
ALLEN ALLEN AYE FORGES. FOR
JUST SIDE CABALLERO CABALLERO
AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
HUESO HUESO AYE JACKSON JACKSON
AYE MONEY MONNING AYE THE FOOLS
OUT WITH. NINE BILLS BILL
PASSES WITH NINE VOTES
CONGRADULATIONS. A LOT OF
THINGS. ARE GOING TO JOIN THE
MEETING WERE ADJOURNED. HI I
HAVE A- WHATEVER IT WAS